eine reihe seltsamer türme die in der
nordsee vor sich hin rosten da draußen
zu wohnen muss sehr speziell und
ziemlich gruselig gewesen sein
eine mysteriöse beton pyramide die in
mittleren westen der usa emporragt
die gesamte umgebung wird bedrohlich
eine verfallene burg im stil des
mittelalters mitten in einer
amerikanischen großstadt
in luks es sieht aus als hätte jemand
ein mittelalterliches gemäuer aus
frankreich nach philadelphia verlegt
und eine der größten maschinen die je
gebaut wurden zurückgelassen auf einem
feld in brandenburg
die ausmaße haut einen echt von den
socken
sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten der welt mit
das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten dann würden
diese anlagen aufgegeben manche sind
heute lebensgefährlich verseucht nur ein
fernes echo hallt noch von den menschen
die einst hier lebten und arbeiteten
was bleibt sind offene fragen und
ungelöste rätsel
[Musik]
die ostküste englands
an der mündung der themse steht eine
gruppe seltsamer rosten der bauten wie
überbleibsel aus den krieg der welten
es sieht aus als würde da ein alien
wache stehen
es ragt aus dem wasser im ohr wie ein
teil einer außerirdischen zivilisation
ein absolut überraschende anwalt
7 riesige stählerne kästen mit einem
gewicht von über 500 tonnen ragen fast
25 meter weit aus den fluten empor
sie ruhen auf je vier langen
betonstützen
[Musik]
da draußen zu leben war sicher ganz
schön speziell und ziemlich gruselig man
war zwar nicht fernab von gut und böse
aber einsam und beängstigend was
bestimmt
der rostige stellen ist erahnen dass
diese mysteriösen worten seit jahren
verlassen sind
aber was veranlasste ingenieure diese
seltsamen bauwerke an einem so
unwirtlichen ort zu erschaffen was war
ihr zweck und warum hat man sie
aufgegeben
[Musik]
1943 der zweite weltkrieg steht an einem
wendepunkt die luftstreitkräfte der
alliierten bedienen sich einer neuen
taktik des flächenbombardements stand
auf industrielle ziele fliegen tausende
britischer und amerikanischer bomber
rund um die uhr massive luftangriffe auf
zivile ballungszentren in deutschland
hitler ist außer sich und plant london
in einer vernichtenden luftoffensive den
erdboden gleich zu machen
das britische militär entwickelt
daraufhin ein streng geheimes
verteidigungs projekt um das herz des
mächtigen britischen imperiums zu
schützen
die themse ist entscheidend für das
fortbestehen londons über diese
lebensader können versorgungsgüter in
die hauptstadt gelangen während panzer
flugzeuge und schiffe die dort in den
fabriken entstehen an die front
geliefert werden
churchill und die briten mussten
sicherstellen dass niemals wieder jemand
über die themse nach london einfliegen
dabei entstehen diese nie dagewesenen
worten
oft ging wirklich solide praktische
lösungen aus sehr schwierigen oder
tragischen situationen hervor
die britische lösung für die gefahr
durch die nazis die see festungen von
websense
[Musik]
sie sind teil einer verteidigungslinie
mit schwerem flugabwehrgeschütz entlang
der themse mündung
[Musik]
es herrschte totale krieg und in so
einem krieg lässt man den fluss denen
die eigene metropole führt nicht
ungeschützt
aber was können diese bauten im kampf
gegen die luftwaffe ausrichten und wie
groß ist ihre rolle im sieg gegen nazi
deutschland
[Musik]
1942 die bauarbeiten beginnen in der
vergangenheit hat sich das anlegen von
verteidigungsstellungen in mehr als
langwierig und komplex erwiesen aber bei
diesem projekt setzen die ingenieure auf
eine neue bautechnik und die fängt mit
der vorfertigung an land
eine befestigungsanlage an einem leicht
zugänglichen ort zu bauen und dann übers
wasser an eine strategisch günstige
stelle zu bringen war eine bahnbrechende
und äußerst bedeutende neuerungen für
offshore-projekte
jeder ton besteht aus einer beton gitter
plattform mit schrägen beinen darauf
steht ein zweistöckiger unterkunfts bau
mit einem geschütz stand oben drauf
[Musik]
beim entwurf dieser türme kamen zwei
grundlegende prinzipien der baustatik
zum tragen
zunächst hat man dafür gesorgt dass der
schwerpunkt der bauten möglichst niedrig
liegt denn das sorgt für mehr stabilität
darüber hinaus hat man auf eine dreiecks
form gesetzt es gibt ein breites
fundament und die stützen laufen schräg
nach oben zusammen damit hat man eine
ähnliche stabilität über einem dreieck
und dieser belastbare form gefällt
baustatiker extrem gut
diese stützen tragen kisten mit einem
gewicht von über 500 tonnen
sie werden in gravesend in kent
gefertigt und dann per schlepper an ihre
position transportiert und aufgestellt
drei gruppen aus je sieben türmen werden
zur verteidigung der themse angelegt die
meisten davon mit schwerem
flugabwehrgeschütz ausgestattet
[Musik]
david phillips ist im projekt red sense
aktiv dass sich dafür einsetzt diese
historischen bauwerke zu erhalten und in
stand zu setzen
das hier ist das herz des ganzen die 94
mm flak geschütze auf den geschütztürmen
diese waffe war äußerst wirksam sie
wurde per radar und feuerleiter anlage
gesteuert das war eine vorrichtung die
zwischen radar und waffel geschaltet war
und sie automatisch auf das ziel
ausrichten konnte
ende des jahres 1943 die festungen an
der themse sind einsatzbereit
jetzt müssen sie nur noch benannt werden
pro anlage werden 165 soldaten gebraucht
[Musik]
an geschützt selbst waren zwei einheiten
im einsatz und dazu jede menge personal
im kontrollturm und am suchscheinwerfer
die soldaten sind je vier wochen am
stück auf diesen entlegenen isolierten
festungen stationiert jederzeit bereit
auf herannahende flugzeuge zu reagieren
hier wurden die geschosse verstaut
ringsherum am geschützturm lagen sie
bereit man brachte sie von der
waffenkammer in diese fächer
die lebensbedingungen hier können brutal
sein
da es sich um eine militärische anlage
handelte wurde der menschliche faktor
wohl eher vernachlässigt
priorität hatte ob sie die wetter und
feindlichen angriffen trotzen konnte
dann erst ging es um die
bequemlichkeiten für die besatzung mehr
[Musik]
da wurden abertausende geschosse
eingesetzt um einige wenige deutsche
flugzeuge abzuschießen
und wenn dafür soldaten und seeleute
unter miserablen bedingungen wind und
wetter in der nordsee ausharren müssen
mit nur wenig trinkwasser und kaum
nachschub an versorgung dann ist das
eben so
[Musik]
die besatzungen trotzten den widrigen
bedingungen und verteidigen das
einfallstor in die englische hauptstadt
und das mit großem erfolg sie holen 22
deutsche flieger vom himmel und auch im
sommer 1944 versenken sie 30 von hitlers
v1 vergeltungs waffen auf dem weg nach
london
[Musik]
dass die flugabwehr jeden ins visier
nahmen er versuchte über die themse nach
london zu gelangen schränkt die
möglichkeiten der deutschen dramatisch
ein
ihre bomber die london während des blitz
kriegs angriffen konnten nicht einfach
der themse folgen und london
bombardieren
ziele präzise zu treffen ist für bomber
im zweiten weltkrieg äußerst schwierig
schlüsse stellen eine wertvolle
orientierungshilfe dar die es den cruze
leichter macht sich ihren weg zum
angriffsziel zu bahnen die themse als
wegweiser auszuschalten verringert die
zerstörungskraft deutsche bomber
erheblich
diese seltsam anmutenden
befestigungsanlagen sind ein
außergewöhnlicher baulicher erfolg und
einer der wegbereiter für den alliierten
sieg im jahr 1945
nachdem sie ihren zweck erfüllt haben
stellt die britische regierung sie 1956
außer dienst und überlässt sie ihrem
schicksal
heute sind noch sieben der original
türme von websense erhalten und trotzen
der korrosion
bis heute stehen sagt viel über die
qualität der entwürfe der bauweise und
ihre nutzung aus
der kampf um die erhaltung dieser
geschichtsträchtigen anlagen ist noch
nicht entschieden aber ohne dringend
benötigte mittel werden sie irgendwann
den elementen zum opfer fallen
bauwerke halten nicht ewig und diese
haben ihren zweck erfüllt das ist oft
nicht leicht aber manchmal müssen wir
eben akzeptieren dass dinge endlich sein
der us-bundesstaat north dakota hier nur
rund 25 kilometer von der kanadischen
grenze entfernt steht eines der
verblüffendsten und mysteriösesten
bauwerke amerikas
auf einem erdwall rat diese 24 meter
hohe betonpyramide in die landschaft
dieses ding ist echt unheimlich
das ist eines der merkwürdigsten
bauwerke in den usa überhaupt
die gesamte umgebung wirkt irgendwie
bedrohlich
fenster sind keine zu sehen die
ansonsten nackten wände die um 56 grad
abfallen werden von seltsamen weißen
kreisen geziert
man steht davor etwas völlig fremd
anmutenden einem riesen bauwerk dass wir
eine art pyramide wirkt
der bau steht mitten auf einem 190
hektar großen feld um ihn herum dutzende
mysteriöser einstiegsluke
sicherheitszäune und verfallener
wachposten
dies ist kein gewöhnlicher
industriekomplex
aus der nähe sieht man dass es eine art
militärische anlage war aber was für
eine diese monolithischen strukturen die
aus dem boden ragen ein beton parkplatz
voller einstiegsluke und pfeiler was ist
das von wem und warum wurde es erbaut
und warum wurde diese riesige pyramide
sich selbst überlassen
anfang der 1960 er jahre das wettrüsten
zwischen sowjetunion und vereinigten
staaten im kalten krieg erreicht einen
kritischen punkt
innerhalb der us streitkräfte wird
hitzig darüber diskutiert wie das land
und seine raketen arsenal am besten vor
der vernichtung durch sowjetische
interkontinental raketen zu schützen
seien
[Musik]
in den 1960 er jahren war die
öffentliche vorstellung von einem
atomkrieg untrennbar mit der von einem
völligen vernichtungskrieg verbunden
es drohte das atomare armageddon die
möglichkeit der massenvernichtung
die sowjetunion respektiert in erster
linie militärische macht also mussten
die usa demonstrieren dass ihre
technologie der sowjetischen mindestens
ebenbürtig wenn nicht sogar überlegen
war
die usa gehen neue wege in sachen
militärischer verteidigung und entwerfen
diese anlage dass nico
raketenabwehrsystem
das herz der anlage bildet ein
hochmodernes radarsystem
ist ein einzigartiges radarsystem das
auf dem höhepunkt des kalten krieges und
amerikanischer paranoia entstand
ende der 60er jahre der bau der anlage
beginnt bauteams heben fast 30.000
kubikmeter erde aus um eine riesige gut
16 meter tiefe grube anzulegen sie wird
mit beton ausgekleidet und mit über
20.000 tonnen eisen und stahl zur
abschirmung gegen nukleare
elektromagnetische strahlung verstärkt
im inneren erstrecken sich fast 12.000
quadratmeter fläche über mehrere
stockwerke
dort sind taktisch operative systeme
waffen steuerung und das neue phased
array radar untergebracht
wenn otto wohnt ganz in der nähe und
führt die aufsicht über das ne cola
gelände
die face der antenne spürt über das
computersystem schon aus größerer
entfernung raketen auf die aus russland
kommen bei
der technologie geht es darum eine
virtuelle radar antenne zu schaffen die
unterschiedliche richtungen in den fokus
nehmen kann ohne dass dafür ein riesiges
stahlgeflecht bewegt werden muss
das war top moderne technologie damit
konnten sich die usa sicher fühlen dass
sie im falle eines atom schlags der
sowjets in der lage wären die
sprengköpfe auszuschalten bevor sie
amerikanischen boden erreichen würden
dieses hohe maß an schutz bedarf eines
der fortschrittlichsten
computersysteme der westlichen welt der
computer des radars ist auf eine
rechenleistung von 10 millionen
instruktionen pro sekunde ausgelegt und
tief unterhalb der explosionsgeschützten
pyramide untergebracht er kontrolliert
das dort stationierte arsenal von 46
raketen die in unterirdischen
abschussvorrichtungen lagern sie sollen
herannahende sowjet flugkörper
ausschalten geleitet werden sie dabei
von den riesigen runden randa antennen
an den vier seiten der pyramide die
nicola anlage stieß an die grenzen
damaliger technologie das größte problem
war dass man nur sekunden hatte um zu
entscheiden ob man versuchen sollte die
feindliche raketen abzuschießen oder ob
es sich dabei vielleicht nur um eine
täuschung handelte
um ihren zweck zu erfüllen muss die
anlage gleichzeitig mehrere sowjetischer
atomraketen ins visier nehmen können
wenn das radar eine sowjetische rakete
im anflug entdeckte liebe noch sechs
minuten die abwehrraketen konnten
innerhalb von 30 sekunden ihr ziel
treffen
solange die riesen computer also schnell
genug rechneten konnte die atomare
abwehrraketen rechtzeitig starten um
eine herannahende
interkontinentalrakete der sowjets hoch
zu jahr
1975 es hat fast ein jahrzehnt gedauert
diese technologien zu perfektionieren
schließlich ist eine koma stützpunkt
voll ausgestattet sowohl mit
langstreckenraketen vom typ staaten als
auch kurzstreckenraketen vom typ
sprinter
diese waffen sollen zwei möglichkeiten
bieten feindliche raketen auszuschalten
[Musik]
hier lagerten die sprint paketen diese
weise abdeckung dort besteht vorwiegend
aus fiberglas beim abschluss ging die
rakete direkt durch fieber klasse durch
bei den sparten raketen wird die
abdeckung aus stahl
vor dem abschuss wurde eine sprengladung
funk aktiviert und die abdeckung
geöffnet
schon war die rakete unterwegs sind die
äußere atmosphäre aber
würde dieses hightech
raketenabwehrsystem auch tatsächlich
funktionieren
und warum wurde es aufgegeben
[Musik]
1975 hatte fertige bau über fünf
milliarden dollar verschlungen das
entspreche heute und 20 milliarden euro
diese raketen waren so schnell
treffsicher und radar gesteuert damit
demonstrierten die vereinigten staaten
dass sie praktisch unempfindlich für
sowjetische angriffe waren das sagte den
russen eine höllenangst 1
1976 das politische klima in amerika
ändert sich nach dem watergate skandal
um den darauf folgenden rücktritt
präsident nixon wird jimmy carter ins
amt gewählt und verfolgt eine neue
strategie im kalten krieg
schon zuvor hat die us regierung
entschiedene koma nach nicht einmal
einem halben jahr in voller
gefechtsbereitschaft als um wirksam zur
kriegs vermeidung zu schließen und sich
selbst zu überlassen obwohl
die anlage technisch einsatzfähig war
soll sich die betriebszeit also mit
vollem programm auf nur drei tage
beschränkt haben
[Musik]
sony koma ist wirklich schockierend
wenn wir schon geld verbrennen dann
richtig das ist mit sicherheit eine der
größten steuergeldverschwendung des
kalten krieges wenn nicht aller zeiten
dennoch sind viele experten überzeugt
dass die enormen summen die in den comer
anlage geflossen
tatsächlich dazu beitragen die bedrohung
durch die sowjets abzuwehren wenn man
bedenkt dass es nie zum atomkrieg
gekommen ist hat der amerikanische
steuerzahler vielleicht auch etwas für
sein geld gekriegt
wenn die fünf milliarden blieben die
kosten für atomaren frieden wahren dann
war das gut investiertes geld
[Musik]
heute liegt die nicola anlage verlassen
da in einem entlegenen winkel north
dakotas
[Musik]
es gibt pläne nico mehr als
touristenattraktion zugänglich zu machen
fragt sich warum ich da hin reisen und
geld bezahlen sollte um diese riesige
scheußlichkeit aus beton anzusehen man
könnte es aber auch als einen ort sehen
der daran erinnert dass sich zwei
nationen schlussendlich zusammenrauften
um frieden zu schaffen
obwohl die anlage nur kurz in betrieb
war setzte nico man neue maßstäbe in der
radar und computertechnologie hier wurde
deutlich dass sich der kalte krieg wohl
eher nicht gewinnen ließ indem man den
planeten mit einem teppich aus
atomraketen überzieht
es gibt gute gründe wie komatsu erhalten
und dort die bedeutung dieser anlage zu
erspüren die ansonsten nur ein riesiger
seltsamer betonbau wäre
[Musik]
2400 kilometer entfernt steht mitten in
der dicht bevölkerten großstadt
philadelphia ein ungewöhnlich angelegter
gebäudekomplex mehr
stößt man auf etwas das wie eine
mittelalterliche burg anmutet mit zinnen
und fahnen die auf türmchen wen
es sieht aus als hätte jemand ein
mittelalterliches gemäuer quasi eine
disney vorlage aus frankreich nach
philadelphia verlegen
[Musik]
das gelände erstreckt sich auf gut 4
hektar und ist von meter hohen drei
meter dicken mauern umgeben die es
deutlich aus den häusern und
bürogebäuden de umliegenden straßen
heraus stechen lassen
[Musik]
mit seinen sieben korridoren die sich
vom achteckigen mittel gebäude aus
erstrecken ist der beklemmend wirken der
komplex wie ein riesiges wagenrad
angelegt
[Musik]
es ist völlig dunkel und feucht ein
gespenstischer ort an dem man sich
wirklich nicht aufhalten möchte
es ist echt gruselig
man riecht die modrigen wälder und den
feuchten beton wirklich unheimlich
was war der zweck dieser seltsamen
anlage und warum steht sie heute leer
es ist anfang des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts der us bundesstaat
pennsylvania hat ein problem die
gefängnisse sind überfüllt lassen sich
nur schwer kontrollieren und die
haftbedingungen sind unmenschlich
jahrzehntelang waren gefängnisse kalte
überfüllte bauten in denen die insassen
eingefärbt wurden wie viele
und wo krankheit gewalt und sogar tod
herrschte neben der
also plant man eine ambitionierte neue
einrichtung zur resozialisierung
gefangener das ist ein statement an
cherry ziel ist es ein modernes
gefängnis zu errichten dass alle anderen
überstrahlen und das justizsystem
revolutionieren soll
das war eine direkte reaktion auf
gesellschaftliche neuerungen und damals
ein sehr revolutionäre ansatz
1822 baubeginn an amerikas größte
montoyas zum gefängnis projekt das mit
damals horrenden
780.000 dollar zu buche schlägt
sie ist geschäftsführerin des eastern
state and julie
der architekt der haftanstalt john
havilland musste die bedürfnisse der
menschen berücksichtigen die dort
inhaftiert waren es wurde zentral
geheizt gab eine zentrale sanitäre
versorgung und belüftung es war der
erste ort an dem menschen in einer so
kontrollierten umgebung lebten
das ist dann steht penny chenery in
philadelphia als diese strafvollzugs
einrichtung 1829 eröffnet wird steht sie
im krassen gegensatz zu gewöhnlichen
kommunalen haftanstalten in denen chaos
und gewalt herrschen
es ist so aufgebaut dass die insassen
jeweils ihren eigenen bereich haben
[Musik]
jeder gefangene hatte eine eigene zelle
mit einem kleinen oberlicht darin was
interessant ist denn es war alles auf
gesellschaftliche reform ausgelegt
das oberlicht soll die insassen die
anwesenheit gottes spüren lassen der auf
sie herab liegt
der ansatz war gefangenen nicht einfach
nur zu bestrafen sondern ihnen zeit zu
geben sich selbst zu reflektieren und
buße zu tun also wurden alle gefangenen
in einzelzellen untergebracht sie durfte
man nicht miteinander sprechen sondern
sollten ihre tage in stiller einkehr
verbringen und über ihre taten
nachdenken
zweimal täglich durften sie einzeln ihre
zellen verlassen zur körperlichen
ertüchtigung im hof durch die frische
luft und das sonnenlicht sollten sie
gesund bleiben
die haftanstalt besteht aus 450
einzelzellen in einem normalen gefängnis
bräuchte es eine große anzahl von waren
um derart viele menschen unter kontrolle
zu halten der britische architekt john
heaven and hingegen löst das problem mit
hilfe eines einzigartigen aufbaus
[Musik]
das design ist genial es ist wie ein
wagenrad von dessen name aus die waren
in alle richtungen und den ganzen
zellenblock hinab blicken kann
der aufbau der haftanstalt war äußerst
innovativ von diesem einen punkt aus
konnte eine kleine gruppe von wärtern
das gesamte gefängnis im auge behalten
recht
[Musik]
aber der bau dieser modell anstalt zur
revolutionierung des umgangs mit
straftätern ist nicht billig
[Musik]
es ist eines der kostspieligsten
öffentlichen bauprojekte in der
geschichte der usa
[Musik]
es war 1828 und jeder gefangene hatte
eine eigene beheizte zelle mit
waschbecken und wasserklosett
um das mal zu verdeutlichen
der präsident hatte im weißen haus kein
eigenes wasserklosett so wie diese jungs
die gefangenen saßen in einzelhaft aber
sie bekamen genug zu essen und litten
nicht unter gewalt durch mitgefangene
verständlich dass die initiatoren das
als fortschritt ansehen
kann diese revolutionäre haftanstalt die
gefangenen tatsächlich resozialisieren
und warum wird ihr betrieb eingestellt
schon nach wenigen jahren zeigen sich
erste probleme es sind die 1800 30er
jahre um die wachsende anzahl von
gefangenen unter zu bringen muss die
haftanstalt vergrößert und der aufbau
verändert werden
sie brauchten doppelt so viele zellen um
viel mehr insassen aufzunehmen
all die netten ansätze von wegen
einsamkeit fördere die selbsterkenntnis
das war hinfällig
die anstalt blieb weiterhin im betrieb
aber nicht mehr als das idyllische
gefängnis der zukunft dass sie gewesen
selbst die fortschrittlichen
versorgungseinrichtungen funktionieren
nicht wie geplant
am ende der zellen blut gestanden öfen
die die tunnel unterhalb der zellen
gleichmäßig beheizen sollten aber die
gefangenen in der nähe der öfen litten
an kohlenstoffdioxid vergiftungen und
die am anderen ende an frostbeulen
die wasserklosett wurden zweimal die
woche von wärtern gespült zweimal die
woche der gestank war sagenhaft
auch der ansatz gefangenen streng
voneinander zu trennen erweist sich als
unmöglich durchzusetzen
ursprüngliche einzelzellen der herbergen
bei zwei oder drei insassen
[Musik]
zu beginn des jahrhunderts ist die idee
der einzelunterbringung die zur einkehr
und besserung der gefangenen beitragen
sollte der realität aus überbelegung und
harten unhygienischen bedingungen
gewichen
[Musik]
aber 1929 setzt die anstalt erneut auf
einzelhaft um einen der berüchtigsten
kriminellen aller zeiten zu
resozialisieren
[Musik]
in houston state entry saßen einige
berühmte gefangene ein darunter alten
der wegen einer kleineren straftat zu
einigen jahren verurteilt wurde
er saß acht monate ab obwohl die
ursprüngliche haftstrafe länger gewesen
war er beschrieb seine zeit dort als
locker kein wunder wenn man sein eigenes
sofa isst ein bücherregal und seine
walzer platten in der zelle hat aber
allzu locker war es wohl auch nicht denn
er investierte reichlich schmuggel
einkünfte um die strafe noch weiter zu
verkürzen
trotz der berüchtigten haftbedingungen
bleibt das gefängnis noch über 40 jahre
lang in betrieb
doch 1970 schließt die einst
revolutionäre haftanstalt endgültig ihre
pforten
heute steht das verfallene ist ein
statement anjuli der mitten in der
lebhaften großstadt philadelphia
nach der schließung war zunächst das
gesamte gelände verlassen aber einige
engagierte bürger sagten nein das ist
eine historische stätte wir müssen hier
ein museum einrichten und das ist es
heute und das ist gut so
trotz der vielen schattenseiten wurde
der bahnbrechende aufbau der haftanstalt
vorlage für mehr als 300 gefängnisse
weltweit
das konzept der einzelhaft jedoch wurde
nicht länger als weg zur besserung
krimineller betrachtet sondern als
bestrafung an sich
damals hielt man es für einen sehr
aufgeklärt den sanften weg den
gefangenen zeigt zwar einkehr zu
gewähren aber tatsächlich war es eine
brutale strafe sie monate oder jahrelang
allein in eine zelle zu sparen das ist
nur schwer vorstellbar
[Musik]
über 6000 kilometer entfernt auf der
anderen seite des atlantiks erhebt sich
im brandenburgischen schipkau ein
rostiges stahl ungeheuer über die
landschaft
mitten im saftigen grün steht eine
wahrhaft monströse maschine
man ist völlig geplättet von den
ausmaßen dieses dings
dieses teil sieht aus wie aus star wars
eine riesige konstruktion rund 50 meter
hoch und mit diesem gruselig aussehenden
rad vorne dran
dieser rostige muskelprotz hat drei
gitter ähnliche arme die über ein
geflecht aus stahlseilen miteinander
verbunden sind
[Musik]
das ist wie science fiction man denkt es
sei irgend eine apparatur mit deren
hilfe ein bösartiges genie die
weltherrschaft übernehmen will
wirklich unglaublich
dieser metalle gigant stand nicht immer
nur bewegungslos da zwei riesige raupen
fahrwerke tragen seine fast 4000 tonnen
gewicht
[Musik]
führerstände entlang der ausleger
erinnern daran dass er einst bemannt war
aber wozu diente diese mysteriöse
maschine wer hat sie erbaut und warum
steht sie jetzt verlassen mitten im
nirgendwo
die 1960 die ddr ändert ihre
wirtschaftspolitik mit dem ziel das
industrielle wachstum anzukurbeln
zur versorgung der kraftwerke und um den
energiebedarf zu decken sagt man die
energieressourcen nummer eins an
braunkohle
knapp unterhalb der erdoberfläche liegen
riesige kohlevorkommen aber sie
abzubauen ist kostspielig und äußerst
arbeitsintensiv
1964 entwickelt der maschinenbauer
lauchhammer werk eine lösung für dieses
problem
[Musik]
bei derart großen konstruktionen standen
ingenieure vor zahlreichen
herausforderungen vor allem aufgrund der
schieren größe alles ist so schwer dass
moderne fertigungs materialien an ihre
grenzen stoßen werden
sieht man sich einige elemente der
ausleger an diesem riesen ding genauer
an wird einem schließlich klar wozu es
diente
dies ist schaufelradbagger 258 eine der
größten maschinen die je gebaut wurden
der tagebau bagger sollte erde und
gestein abtragen und so die braunkohle
adern freilegen die knapp unterhalb der
erdoberfläche verlaufen
magath 258 macht im tagebau keine halben
sachen
er trägt meterweise erde mit einer
schaufel ladung ab und sieht einen
riesigen langen graben durch das
erdreich bis er zum ziel kommt zur krone
das laut hammerwerk stellte verschiedene
arten dieser maschinen her aber nur
einen bagger 258
1965 wird er in dienst gestellt
wichtigster bestandteil ist das riesige
schaufelrad es hat einen durchmesser von
über zwölf metern
110.000 kubikmeter erde und gestein kann
es an einem tag bewegen
[Musik]
dieses ding hier tausende tonnen aus und
transportiert sie dann über sein eigenes
förderband ab
währenddessen fährt es unermüdlich
weiter hass und frisst sich durchs
erdreich
maschine trifft es nicht das ist ein
erfahrener fabrik actelion trunks
[Musik]
schaufelradbagger sind äußerst komplex
in ihren bewegungen und funktionen
vorstellen sie erledigen ihre arbeit mit
minimaler menschlicher beteiligung
wenn man sieht wie groß und komplex der
bagger ist sollte man meinen dass es
eine armee von menschenrechte um ihn zu
bedienen aber das ist nicht der fall
es sind nur fünf personen nötig und die
sind alle an bord seine baukosten waren
also vielleicht torrent aber im betrieb
ist er relativ günstig
man muss abwägen ob man eine wirklich
große maschine baut oder dutzende oder
hunderte laster und kleine bagger
einsetzt wenn etwas kaputt geht hat man
natürlich ein problem und der betrieb
steht still aber alles in allem sind
schaufelradbagger so effizient dass sich
das risiko auszahlt
[Musik]
1965 der koloss tritt den dienst an er
ist darauf ausgelegt effizient kohle
freizulegen und arbeitet sich stetig
voran
mit seinem gewicht von fast 4000 tonnen
rückt ihr etwa sechs meter pro minute
vor
damit stellt er wohl kein
geschwindigkeitsrekord auf aber es ist
schon sehr beeindruckend wenn man die
größe und das gewicht dieses dings
bedenkt
tatsächlich ist er so schwer dass der
boden und die straßen die er befährt
speziell verstärkt werden müssen damit
er sie nicht zu staub zum 1
er ist also mobil aber das hat seinen
preis mobility kommen so der post
eine der herausforderungen ist dass man
die schaufeln ständig bewegen muss um
frische erde oder kohle abzutragen der
schaufelradbagger muss sich drehen um
den schaufeln neuer angriffsfläche zu
geben und das ganze gerät muss vorwärts
fahren um neue bereiche auszuheben
und das ist nicht das einzig heikle am
betrieb dieses giganten
wir sind gleich die vielen arme des
baggers ins auge gefallen
nach hinten erstreckt sich der verlader
ausleger der die abgetragene erde in
bereitstehende laster transportiert die
sie dann weg fahren
und dafür braucht es ein gegengewicht
auslegen damit die maschine nicht durch
die kräfte und die belastung beim graben
einfach vornüber kippt
[Musik]
jahrzehntelanges bagger 258 erfolgreich
im ostdeutschen tagebau aktiv
auch nach der wiedervereinigung trägt er
weiterhin dazu bei den energiebedarf im
land zu decken bis er 2002 schließlich
außer dienst gestellt wird
letztlich gibt es für ihn einfach nichts
mehr abzubauen und er geht in rente
[Musik]
heute steht der schaufelradbagger auf
einem ruhigen fällt in der lausitz aber
seine einsatzzeit hat unauslöschliche
spuren hinterlassen
[Musik]
das problem mit großen schaufelradbagger
ist er sie aus menschen gemachten
baustoffen und metallen bestehen deren
beständigkeit zu wünschen übrig lässt
sie für kommende generationen zu
bewahren wäre enorm teuer sie auf einem
feld abzustellen ist vielleicht die
beste lösung
man hat bagger 2 580 selbst und den
elementen überlassen aber vielleicht ist
das gar nicht so schlecht fakt ist dass
wir nach wie vor von fossilen
brennstoffen abhängig sind und für mich
ist diese maschine eine erinnerung und
ein denkmal für die geniale tät die es
braucht um sich die ressourcen der erde
so zunutze zu machen wie wir es tun
[Musik]
heute sind sie verlassen aber sie
zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten worten der welt
diese verfallenden konstruktionen sind
ein echo der vergangenheit sie erzählen
von krieg und schrecken aber auch von
entdeckergeist und fortschritt
[Musik]